Since I've been on a low animal protein diet, my thyroid panel is not as good as before,
although I am taking the same part of my thyroid.
If this is because of my diet, can I use some kind of amino acids without glutamate, glutamine?
Also I have found out, without certain amino acids, the detox does not happen in the body.
There's amino acids that you need, those are called essential amino acids.
And then there's also a group of amino acids called non-essential amino acids,
because they're not essential for you to consume in your diet because your body makes them out of other amino acids.
So I remember glutamide is the amino acid.
It actually converts to glutamate through a certain gene sequence, an enzyme that's made through the glutamate.
The glutamate, the glutamate, the glutamate, the glutamate, and the glutamate is under a transmitter.
So that's another issue with glutamate.
If a person is got a diet for glutamate, even if they don't have cancer,
and they have defects in that gene, they can convert that glutamate quite quickly.
There's an excitatory neurotransmitter that can cause OCD, anxiety, ADD, ADHD issues.
And that's a huge problem with young people, with ADD and ADHD.
So it older people typically, anxiety, and OCD.
So yes, ADD, you know, you could get all your amino acids through plant-based proteins as well.
But you know, I think this person, we started on some animal proteins.
And lots of times people, you know, I am not a person who thinks everybody should be a vegetarian.
And certainly not.
And if your cancer's not driven through certain meats, I think you should be eating them.
I think they can really give you a lot of, not just joy, but I think it can give you a lot of energy.
So it's a good source of your B vitamins, and it's sometimes necessary to help build your blood.